(oriental instrumental music)
- [Voiceover] The Shaolin monks of China
are an ancient order
surrounded in mystery.
They spend their lives learning kung fu
and Buddhist philosophy.
- [Voiceover] After defecting
from communist China,
one Shaolin monk found
himself living in New York,
training some unique clients
ranging from movie stars
to hip hop artists.
- [Voiceover] As Shi Yan
Ming's popularity grew,
his teachings began
attracting the attention
of one of New York's most
famous hip hop artists.
- Just a train.
- [Voiceover] The shifu has spent years
training with RZA from Wu-Tang Clan,
even going so far as to
appear in the music video
for Shaolin Temple.
(inaudible speaking)
- [Voiceover] But Shi Yan
Ming strongly believes
that the benefits of Shaolin
can be adapted for any individual.
(peaceful instrumental music)